from the director who still doesn't know
how to quit while he's ahead comes the
fifth Tokyo movie in the second
installment of the second trilogy
that's so bloated by now even its own
characters are getting bored we got
round in sons we're never gonna reach
the mountain always we are lost too long
the hobbit the desolation of smaug me
joy little earth's other shorter less
interesting fellowship as they continue
their slow journey to Scrooge McDuck
falls to retrieve yet another piece of
jewelry that corrupts those who seek it
the Arkenstone is precious to you beyond
measure
curses and Bumble from one unimportant
set piece to another as they're captured
by spiders captured by elves captured by
man and captured by orcs too bad they
couldn't capture any of the magic of the
original trilogy am i right experienced
a nearly three hour movie with the plot
of one-third of a children's novel that
will have audiences everywhere saying oh
my god it's still going full of things
you've already seen like flashbacks to
characters you already know us for the
Christmas of my members Gandalf
I know flashbacks to things you already
saw in the first Hobbit the day that
Smaug destroyed Dale flashbacks inside a
flashbacks and an attempt at a
mysterious origin story for a villain we
already know the identity of attack nice
a shadow that grows in the dark they're
gonna - we know it's cooking sarin get
to the dragon already huh so return to
New Zealand's most breathtaking
green-screen studios again where tiny
sections of the book will be stretched
in two hours of overly CG filler super
elf murder sprees The Hobbit the ride
the cartoon and things that weren't even
in the book like Gandalf sidequest
Laketown politics these fish are illegal
K from lost and a creepy romance between
the hot Wharf and K from lost aren't you
going to search me I could have anything
down my trousers gross so finally
witness the conclusion of their endless
journey to the slopes of the Lonely
Mountain only to watch them give up
after about 10 minutes of banging on a
closed door and thrill as they finally
confront the talking dragon smaug in a
slapstick battle so over-the-top it ends
with them building a giant dwarf that
covers him in gold which does nothing
then it ends what have we done what
indeed Bilbo what indeed starring Morgan
Freeman
Dumbledore Legoland Dragon Con
evangelist Lily Sarah and duck chief Tom
Bombadil Stephen Colbert for some reason
an adventurer until he took an arrow to
the knee random CGI orc go and number
two bard to death and the one to blame
The Hobbit two down one to go
this is the prequel right so how come
legless looks so much more mature is he
like an elf Benjamin Button be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers want
more awesome Hobbit stuff then please
check out our pals at men-at-arms to
watch them build a real-life version of
Saiyans mace and then be sure to see
superfan bills where one go to the ring
span and his two cats get the one kitty
litter box to rule them all oopsy poopsy
's lemon troop sees if you value your
lives
give me potatoes my butt itches doth
mother know you weareth her drapes would
anybody like some pound cake press f to
pay respects i gotta wrap it up they're
gonna kick us out of here at the end of
the day I gotta give it to howl